au cours de ces cinq dernières années le
corps médical m'a rattrapé neuf fois in
extrémiste
s'il n'y avait pas un meeting
je serais déjà mort pour alain cocq 58
ans mourir devrait être un droit
atteint d'une maladie aussi incurable
que douloureuse il est depuis l'âge de
23 ans sous morphine et en soins
palliatifs en l'absence de législation
en france c'est en suisse que ce
militant a prévu de mettre fin à ses
jours avec insistance déposée par le
député olivier falorni membres du groupe
liberté et territoires la proposition de
loi examinée à l'assemblée ouvre un
droit à une fin de vie libre et choisis
grâce à une assistance médicalisée
active pour toute personne capable
majeure en phase avancée ou terminale
d'une affection grave et incurable
ne pouvant être apaisée ou juger par l
insupportable si la proposition
d'olivier falorni a reçu l'appui de 270
députés de tous bords
dans une tribune parue sur le journal du
dimanche il reste sujet à une forte
opposition politique qui a déposé trois
mille amendements
on est dans une dépénalisation de ce que
juridiquement on appelle un homicide
adoptée il ya cinq ans la loi claisse
leonetti instaurer la possibilité d'une
sédation profonde et continue pouvant
mener à la mort mais sans hausse en asie
active
du côté des médecins les craintes
demeurent si 60% d'entre eux seraient
favorables à une légalisation de
l'euthanasie
nombre d'entre eux y voient une trahison
du serment d'hippocrate et demande le
développement des soins palliatifs
fondée sur le soulagement de la douleur
et l'accompagnement personnalisé des
patients pour de nombreux professionnels
la légalisation de l'euthanasie ne fait
que déplacer le problème de la fin de
vie
les partisans de la légalisation de
l'euthanasie veut nous faire croire que
donner la mort résoudrait tous les
problèmes de la fin de vie c'est un
mensonge
pourquoi faudrait-il changer la loi
alors que les soins palliatifs ne sont
pas encore assez répandu et qu'il existe
toujours des services ou l'acharnement
thérapeutique et quotidien à ce jour 26
départements français ne dispose
toujours pas d'une unité de soins
palliatifs à l'étranger des lois en
faveur de l'euthanasie ou du suicide
assisté ont été votées notamment en
suisse en belgique aux pays bas et tout
récemment au portugal en janvier ou en
espagne ce 18 mars
des prises de position qui témoigne
d'une inquiétude concernant la fin de
vie
dans un contexte de crise sanitaire ou
ce questionnement est omniprésent
[Applaudissements]